welcome back to CBS mornings as we told
you at the top of the seven o'clock hour
former president Donald Trump is
traveling to Miami today is due tomorrow
in a courtroom there to respond to his
indictment on 37 felony charges over the
handling of classified documents after
he left the White House he denies
wrongdoing in this case the special
counsel who investigated the case said
the following on Friday
we have one set of laws in this country
and they apply to everyone
applying those laws collecting facts
that's what determines the outcome of an
investigation
nothing more
and nothing less
Republican senator Marco Rubio of
Florida is with us now he is vice chair
of the Senate intelligence committee and
a member of the committee on Foreign
Relations he's also the author of a new
book it's called Decades of decadence
how our spoiled Elites blew America's
inheritance of Liberty security and
prosperity Senator Rubio quite the
subtitle glad to have you here thank you
uh you know what's at stake in the book
actually is relevant to where we need to
start this conversation which is the
indictment of Donald Trump you know uh
the last president to get this much
trouble with the law was Ulysses S Grant
who got a ticket for speeding in his
buggy so this is a big deal to a lot of
people I take it from your tweets over
the weekend though that although the
indictment alleges that the president
held some of the nation's Biggest
Secrets kept them even if even though he
was asked to give them back and then
lied to try to cover it up even though
all that happened according to the
indictment you don't think it should
have been brought yeah for I picked a
great week to come up with it didn't I
because you wrote a book before this
yeah of course no no look I mean I don't
think there should be classified
documents at Mar-A-Lago at Joe Biden's
Garage on Hillary Clinton's server I
mean there's a proper rated story
there's a law around that so I do think
however that when you bring an
indictment like this it's not done in
isolation it's not done in a vacuum you
got to take a lot of things into account
there's no allegation that there was
harm done to the to the National
Security there's no allegation that he
sold it to a foreign power or that it
was traffic to somebody else or that
anybody got access to it and you have to
weigh that the harm of that versus or
the lack thereof on the harm that this
indictment does to the country this is
deeply divisive this is a polarized and
deeply divided country we're on the East
17 months away from the election you're
indicting the leading candidate the
likely nominee against the incumbent
president you're already seeing attacks
on the judges because
though Senator he did something wrong he
was given plenty of opportunity to
return to return this material and he
did not do it and you have to weigh all
of that if proven right because
indictments are one-sided documents
offered by the prosecution that's why
they have trials you have to weigh that
against the overall harm of the
country's prosecutorial discretion
happens all the time but when you weigh
the two things which is there wasn't
there's no allegation of harm to the
country or national security there's no
allegation in there that it was sold to
somebody not that they should have been
there but there's not and then you weigh
that against a certain harm of this
indictment because it will be certain
harm this will now put our all of our
institutions into tremendous crisis the
judge will be attacked the process will
be attacked the Department of Justice
will be attacked the prosecutor will be
attacked do you think Donald Trump can
defend his actions based on what's in
the indictment well look I'm not going
to give legal advice on his deal you
know what's happening here I don't know
all the facts I know it's in the
indictment I don't know his defense I
haven't heard from his attorneys I've
already told you those documents should
not have been there like this shouldn't
have been in Biden's garage but the
indictment is a separate thing you're
bringing an indictment that based
basically alleges no real damage to the
National Security not that it excuses it
versus what we're going to see now we're
going to subject this country to a
divisive spectacle at a time when we're
dealing with these major issues that I
talk about in this book we're going to
spend the next 17 months arguing over
the senator let me ask you something
just so you can simplify this for the
viewer a little bit you say there's a
proper way to store these documents yes
Trump came out and said there can be a
process but there doesn't have to be he
went on to say that if you're a
president you can declass it declassify
anything just by thinking about it are
there proper steps is there is there
protocol how do you declassify well look
the president has brought Authority when
you're president to declassify whatever
you want that's by thinking about it
hold on well obviously you got it
there's paper you got to let everybody
else know that oh there's plastic okay
you got to let everybody else know
that's declassified you have to do a
process but I don't think the argument
here in my mind again I'm not his legal
counsel right they'll leave that to his
lawyers I think that is that these are
Declassified documents the storage is
the issue these things are generally
kept in a safe and not not in boxes
like in Joe Biden's garage like what
happened you know with with uh vice
president Pence like what's happened in
the past but when Hillary Clinton though
was accused of mishandling classified
documents you described her actions as
disqualifying her from being
commander-in-chief how is this different
well and I think those are arguments
that President Trump's opponents will
use against him in an election which if
the guy doesn't know how to handle
classified documents that's different
from let's now have an indictment where
we're going to try to put this guy in
jail for the rest of his life because
that's what they're trying to do here
um and what that will mean to the
country and the inability as a result of
this look this is already a very
volatile political situation we're
living how did it get so that's one of
the questions I think we need to put a
couple things straight for the record it
you're right the the indictment does not
say there was harmed in National
Security it also doesn't exclude the
fact and we all saw how the documents
were stored the difference in this case
according to the allegations and all the
other cases Hillary Clinton Joe Biden
Mike Pence you name it is the willful
nature of it over a very long period of
time more than a year and a half and so
I wonder and people will argue about
what the fairness this and the two-tier
this and all that and that's an argument
for Republicans to have and they're
going to win some people over on that
but the question is did the former
president drag the country into this
because of his own behavior well once
again yeah but at the end of the day
going back to what I said about why this
can't be analyzed in a vacuum the reason
why this will be deeply divisive is
there are plenty of people out there
myself included that using Common Sense
will say hold on a second Sandy Berger
he was a national security advisor to
President Clinton he actually stuffed
classified information in his stock and
hit it under a trailer okay and he was
charged with misdemeanors as a result of
that not a felony not a life sentence
like what they're asking for here on top
of everything else that the
imprecedented nature of this is when
you're going to prosecute the likely
nominee of the Republican party to run
against an incumbent president that
alone is political in nature you have to
know that and take that into account
when you decide what to charge them with
how to bring this action when to bring
this action and now as a result of it is
we are going to be subjected as a
country to a 17-month circus and it's
probably not done and by the way this
has to be taken in the context of two
impeachments
a three years spent chasing a dossier
that turned out not to be true charges
here in Manhattan potential charges out
of D.C that are still awaiting whatever
happens out of Georgia I mean this is
this is a circus it's a mess so let's
talk about the book and keep in mind
when we talk about the book that the
Wall Street Journal makes all the points
you're making in an op-ed today but also
says that the Republican voter base
Republicans deserve a leader who is more
competent and who has better character
than the former president well that's
why we'll help the problems yeah and
they're going to vote on that in Iowa
and New Hampshire I've been through that
process myself and voters will make that
decision so to solve the problems in
that book right there it's about in your
view the slide of America from the 1980s
to the present day what do you think the
biggest issue is well our biggest issue
is threefold number one is that well the
big essential issue is the Cold War
ended and we pretended that things like
nation state no longer exists we thought
everyone was going to become a free
enterprise democracy and that the market
could fix every problem right then that
everybody's now a consumer or an
investor and that's not that wasn't true
so we made three terrible assumptions
number one that you can divorce economy
from the well being a people so it
doesn't matter whether we're losing jobs
or industrial capacity we can't make
things anymore the important thing is
companies are making a lot of money and
Wall Street looks good and the stock
market's doing well that's proven not to
be the case because economic life isn't
just about how much money is being made
it's whether you're creating the kinds
of jobs that allow people to be parents
to have communities that hold your
country together the second is foolish
decisions about other countries you know
and the belief that other countries
didn't view themselves as a country they
viewed themselves as citizens of the
world and the third is this deeply
divisive cultural war that we have going
on in our country in which people
literally hate each other won't even
speak to each other members of family
hate each other we don't even know each
other and we hate each other you say on
209 despite the challenges you remain
optimistic about America you say we're
in desperate need of leadership do you
think Donald Trump is the leader that we
need now I know the voters will decide
but I'm asking you Senator Marco Rubio
with all that you know of and you know
more than most uh given your background
do you think he is the person to be the
next leader of this country well I think
you do a better job than Joe Biden has
done
and a heartbeat because I'll tell you
this a lot of the ideas that we've been
proposing as an example up until and I
ran against Donald Trump okay he won the
Primary but up until Donald Trump was a
nominee of the Republican party with all
the things people may not like about him
the Republican party is Orthodoxy didn't
allow you to challenge things like what
do you do when the market outcome is not
good for America
what do we do with all this money that's
flowing out of American Capital markets
and helping China build its capacity at
our expense what do we do when yes
cheaper prices at the store but a
million Americans lost their jobs
because of an industrial capacity you
gave away he challenged that Republican
Orthodoxy and opened the door for us to
have a lot of the conversations but you
have many people who have worked with
Donald Trump Bill Burr speaking out
Chris Christie is speaking out who said
that he is not qualified to be president
of the United States well and that's why
we have indictment leads us to believe
that he may have broke the law I know
the indictment it has to play itself out
so but you believe that he is but I mean
and Cornell West thinks that Joe Biden
shouldn't be president and Robert Kenney
Jr is running out there is for president
so both sides look that's we have a
vibrant political process people can
debate about who they think it should be
voters are going to make that decision
okay the bottom line is that that our
Republic will produce a president the
policies is what we need to hold them to
and that's what I'm hoping to advance
with this Senator this is a very
readable book it's 214 pages and I think
people should add the 49 pages of the
indictment I wanted to make it 213.
don't listen I was talking about the 49
but this book here is about what's at
stake Senator Marco Rubio thank you very
much it's called Decades of decadence it
goes on sale tomorrow wherever you like
to buy your books